[Music]  Valentine's Day is tomorrow and of  course as I said a millions of Americans  would be buying gifts making plans for  their loved ones here's the problem  economy is in rough shape at the moment  most people are on a pretty tight budget  so here with some money saving  valentine's day tips is our prop master  bill tell bill take a glass of apple  juice add some alka-seltzer boom  champagne  [Applause]  [Music]  here's another bill with tip thing take  some celery stalks dip it in some red  paint boom  red roses  here's another one take a pair of  underwear rip out the middle boom  crotchless panties  I'm using that one here's another one  hold up a paper plate walk in front of  it  boom moonlight stroll use another one  take a flower stay put here this boom  corsage take a book of Walt Whitman's  poetry put some chocolates inside boom  Whitman sampler  [Applause]